we know what an orthonormal basis is but
the next obvious question is what are
they good for and one of the many
answers to that question is that they
make for good coordinate systems or good
coordinate bases good coordinate systems
for example the standard basis or the
standard coordinates let me write the
standard basis in RN so if we're dealing
with RN so the standard basis standard
basis for our n is equal to well we
could I could write it as e1 e2 and all
of that but I'll actually write out the
vectors you know e 1 is just 1 with a
bunch of zeros all the way e2 and this
is going to be n zeros right there e 2
is going to be 0 1 with a bunch of zeros
all the way and then you're going to go
all the way to en which is going to have
a bunch of zeros and then you're going
to have a 1 the standard basis that
we've been dealing with throughout this
playlist is an orthonormal set is an
ortho orthonormal orthonormal basis it's
an orthonormal basis clearly the length
of any of these guys is 1 if you were to
take this guy dotted with yourself
you're going to get 1 times 1 plus a
bunch of zeros times each other so it's
going to be 1 squared it's going to be 1
and that's true of any of these guys and
clearly they're orthogonal you take the
dot product of any of these guys with
any of the other ones you're going to 1
times 0 and 1 times the 0 and a bunch of
0 so you're going to get 0 so they're
clearly each have lengths of 1 and
they're all orthogonal and clearly this
is a good coordinate system this is a
good coordinate system but what about
other orthonormal basis is obviously
this is you know this is one specific
example I need to show you that all
orthonormal bases make for good
coordinate systems so let's say let's
say I have some set some orthonormal set
of vectors so it says v1 v2
all the way to VK and it is an
orthonormal basis and ortho normal
orthonormal basis for some subspace for
for some subspace V and this is a K
dimensional subspace because you have K
basis vectors in your basis or you have
K vectors in your basis now let's
experiment with this a little bit we I'm
claiming that this would make that the
coordinate system with respect to this
is good but what does it mean to be good
I mean the standard basis is is is good
but you know that's just because we use
it in you know it seems to be easy to
deal with but let's see what I when I
say good in this context what do I mean
so let's experiment if I say that some
vector X is a member of V that means
that X can be represented as a linear
combination of these characters up here
so X X can be represented as some
constant times v1 plus some constant
times v2 plus you know the constant
times VI all the way if you just keep
going all the way to the Kait constant
times VK that's what being a member of
the subspace me is a subspace of spanned
by these guys so this guy can be
represented in your combination of those
guys now what happens if we take the dot
product of both sides of this equation
with V I so I'm going to take VI I'm
gonna dot both of these sides VI so I
get VI dotted with X is going to be
equal to what well it's going to be we
could just put the constants out it's
going to be c1 times VI
dot v1 plus c2 times VI dot v2 plus all
the way to C I times VI dot VI and then
you keep going plus all the way to CK
times VI dot VK now this is an
orthonormal set that means if I take
vectors that are different than each
other in our in our basis right here
that if you take their dot product
you're going to get zero they're
orthogonal to each other so these are
two different vectors in our set they're
going to be orthogonal so this term is
going to be 0 is going to be 0 times c1
so it's going to be 0 this term is also
going to be 0 assuming that I isn't 2
let's just assume that this term over
here let's assume that I isn't K it's
also going to be equal to 0 so all of
the terms are going to be 0 except for
the case where V sub I is equal to well
in this case V sub I except for the case
where this subscript is equal to that
subscript and then what is V sub I dot V
sub I well this is you know orthonormal
has two parts there are THOG '''l to
each other and they're each normalized
or they each have length one so V sub I
V sub I dot with V sub I is going to be
equal to 1 so this whole equation has
simplified to V sub I which is one of
these guys it's the IP of our basis set
dot X where X is just any member of the
subspace is equal to the only thing
that's left over is 1 times CI is 1
times CI so it's just equal to CI now
why is this useful you know we were just
experimenting around and we got this
nice little result here why is this
useful in terms of in terms of having a
coordinate system with respect to this
basis so let's remind ourselves what a
coordinate system is here so if we want
to if we wanted to represent the vector
X which is a member of our subspace with
coordinates that are with respect to
this basis of the subspace right the
subscales can have many bases but this
is the basis that we're choosing so we
want to write X with respect to the
basis B what do we do with the
coordinates are going to just be are
just going to be the coefficients on the
different basis vectors this is all a
bit of review right it's going to be c1
c2 you're going to go down to C I and
then you're going to go down to all the
way to CK you're going to have K terms
because this is a K dimensional sub
space now normally this is not such an
easy thing to figure out if I give you
some vector X I mean we've seen it
before if that you get if you have well
if you have X represented it in a in B
coordinate system then you can multiply
it times the change of basis metrics and
you can the change of basis matrix and
you can just get regular X but if you
want if you have regular X and you need
to find this u1 you know if if c is
invertible then you can apply this
equation right here which isn't always
the case this is only if c is invertible
only if c invertible and first of all c
will not always be invertible if this
isn't a square matrix and this isn't
going to apply so this is one way that
if I if I give you your X to get your B
representation of X but if C isn't
invertible then you just gonna have to
solve this equation you're going to have
something on the right hand side here
you're going to have a change of basis
matrix and then you're gonna have to
solve that equation so it's kind of a
you know for an arbitrary basis that can
be pretty painful but what do we have
here we have a very simple solution for
finding the different coordinates of X
so this is the same thing as B equal to
c1 is just going to be equal to my first
basis vector dotted with X right we say
CI is just the a the basis vector dotted
with X so C 1 is going to be the first
basis vector dotted with X C 2 is going
to be my second basis vector dotted with
X and you're going to go all the way
down to CK is going to be is going to be
my caithe basis vector dotted with X let
me show you that this is actually easier
so let me let's do a concrete a concrete
example so let's say I want to leave I
want to leave this result up here let's
say that I have two vectors let's say
that V 1 is the vector is the vector
three-fifths let me write it this way
let's say it's three over five and four
or over five and that V 2 is equal to V
2 is equal to minus 4/5 3/5 3/5 and
let's say that the set B is equal to
it's comprised of just those two vectors
V 1 and V 2
now I'm claiming or I'm about to claim
that this is an orthonormal set
let me just let's just prove it to
ourselves so what is the length of V 1
squared well that's just V 1 dotted with
itself so that's 3/5 squared which is 9
25th
plus 4/5 squared which is 16 25th which
is equal to 25 over 25 which is equal to
1 so this this guy definitely has length
1 what is the length of V 2 squared well
it's going to be this guy squared
negative 4/5 squared is 9 25th
3 sorry minus 4/5 squared is plus 16
25th and then 3/5 squared is 9 25th and
once again the length squared is going
to be 1 or the length is going to be 1
so both of these guys definitely have
length 1 and now we just have to verify
that there are thuggin 'old with respect
to each other so what is v1 dot v2 it's
going to be 3/5 times minus 4/5 so it's
going to be minus 12 25th
4/5 times 3/5 which is going to be plus
12 25th which is equal to 0 so these
guys are definitely orthogonal with
respect to each other and their lengths
are 1 so this is definitely an
orthonormal orthonormal orthonormal set
and so that also tells us that they're
linearly independent so let's say that
let's say that my set B is the basis the
basis for for some set for some for some
subspace V for some subspace V and let's
say
let's say and actually it's not a we
don't have to say that it's the basis
for r2 it's a basis for r2 how do we
know it's a basis for r2 I have I have
two linearly independent vectors I have
two linearly independent vectors that in
my basis and it's spanning a
two-dimensional space r2 so this can be
a basis for all of our two now now given
what we've seen already let's pick some
random member of r2 so if we pick some
random member of r2 let's say that X is
equal to I don't know I'm just going to
pick some random numbers 9 and minus 2 9
and minus 2 if we didn't know this was
an orthonormal basis and we wanted to
figure out we wanted to figure out X in
these coordinates what we would have to
do is we would have to create the change
of basis matrix so the change of basis
matrix would be 3 let me write it like
would be 3/5 4/5 minus 4/5 and then 3/5
we would say that times my B coordinate
representation of X is going to be equal
to my regular representation of X or my
my standard coordinates of X and I would
have to solve this two-by-two system and
in the 2 by 2 case it's not so bad but
we have this neat tool here for
orthonormal sets or orthonormal basis so
instead of doing solving this equation
we can just we can just say that X X
represented in B coordinates our goal is
going to be equal to let me scroll down
a little bit it's going to be equal to
v1 which is this guy right here dotted
with X so it's going to be v1 dot X dot
X and then this guy right here is just
going to be V 2 X and I can do this
because this is an orthonormal
orthonormal basis and what is this equal
to X is 9 minus 2x is 9 minus 2 let me X
is 9 minus 2 if I dot that with v1
I get 9 times 3/5 which is 27 fifths
right 27 / 5 9 times 3 is 27 / 5 + + +
minus 2 times 4/5 so that's minus 8/5
right minus 2 times 4/5 is minus 8/5
minus 8/5 and then the second term is V
- X so V - X I get 9 times just cool up
a little bit 9 times minus 4/5 that's
minus 36 over 5 plus minus 2 times 3/5
so that's plus minus 2 times 3/5 is
minus 6/5 so the B coordinate
representation of X just being able to
use this property right here of
orthonormal bases is equal to what is
this 27 minus 8 is 19 over 5 and then -
36 minus 6 is minus 42 over 5 not a
pretty answer but it you know we would
have had this ugly answer either way we
solve it but hopefully you see that when
we have an orthonormal basis solving for
solving for the coordinates with respect
to that basis becomes a lot easier and
this was just a this is just a example
in r2 you can imagine how difficult
could be if you start dealing with you
know if you're if you start dealing with
our for our 100 then all of a sudden
solving these systems aren't so easy but
taking dot products are always fairly
straightforward so one is earlier in
this video when I said orthonormal basis
you know what are they good for and I
said you know well the standard basis is
good so these are good coordinate
systems we've used it before you know I
didn't really put a lot of context to
one around what it meant to be good but
now we see one version of what it's good
it's very easy to find coordinates to
find coordinates in an orthonormal in an
orthonormal basis record is with respect
to an orthonormal basis